You know, I hate it when I'm right about horrible
things.
I really do.
But Americans are now the dangerous disease
carrying foreigners, just like I predicted
we would be some months ago.
And I hate it.
I'm not happy about this.
I'm not gloating about this.
It personally upsets me that this is the reality.
Much of the world, at least for now, is safely
returning to normality.
Friends in Belgium, France, a lot of different
places, masks required on public transit.
Things are more spaced out at restaurants,
but increasingly unnormal existence is resuming
in countries that have successfully fought
the virus.
That is not the case in the United States.
We are not allowed to go to many parts of
the world.
The travel bans, which we are known for, are
now against us because corona virus is raging
here.
The American right wing is all about banning
others, but it is we who are now banned because
we are the danger.
Visitors from 15 different countries can now
go to the European Union.
Not Americans.
It's too dangerous.
There's too much coronavirus here.
We've failed.
We are on a list, so to speak.
The American right has been demonizing others
as those who, like Tucker Carlson said on
his Fox News program some months ago, immigrants
make our country dirtier and poorer.
That was Tucker Carlson.
Well, the American right has said it's foreigners
who bring disease.
The American right has said we need to stop
them from coming here.
But now we're the ones that are too risky
for other countries to let us in.
As Erica Lee writes in a Washington Post piece,
there is a very long history of tying foreigners
to disease here in the United States.
You go back to the seventeen hundreds Germans
and yellow fever.
They were going to bring yellow fever Irish
in the eighteen hundreds.
They were going to bring cholera.
So many examples.
Chinese immigrants, smallpox and bubonic plague
and leprosy, Jews and tuberculosis.
That's a classic.
Italians and polio in the early nineteen hundreds.
Mexico.
Pins to plague typhus and smallpox.
It's a very long list, and the links between
xenophobia and disease are widespread.
They're long lasting and we've seen much of
the same more recently with Corona virus.
And so understand that Chinese flu, Wu Hahn
flu, cung flu is Donald Trump has repeatedly
called it all of that stuff.
It's just more of the same.
This is not new.
We've seen this in the U.S. since the seventeen
hundreds.
And of course, yeah, the virus originated
in China.
And yet China lied.
And yes, China should be held accountable.
But every country dealt with a virus that
originated in China.
Most countries dealt with that virus that
originated in China far better than we did.
So much better, in fact, that we are now banned
from many of those countries.
It's an embarrassment.
The virus is exploding in huge parts of this
country.
Again, a single day case record yesterday.
I will talk to you later on, by the way.
Texas now two days in a row, setting its single
day case, death record exactly as we would
have predicted when cases started surging
in mid to late June.
This has nothing to do with immigration.
It has to do with a late and terrible testing
program.
Lack of a contact tracing program botched
and too early reopenings reluctance to wear
masks in some states.
And it's now bleeding into the responsible
states, too.
I've been saying for several weeks now, we're
doing great.
Here in Massachusetts.
But it can't last forever when cases are so
high in so many of these other states and
indeed cases and hospitalizations are starting
to trickle up here in Massachusetts.
It's only a little bit, but it's starting
to happen.
We're now the disease carrying foreigners
that have to be banned from other countries.
And it's embarrassing and it's horrifying.
And I hate it.
But I understand why countries have to do
it is our weakness.
Ego is our weakness.
Anti science sentiment is at hyperpolarization.
We won't ever be like those other countries.
Many of us believe that won't ever come to
that.
And now Corona virus has shown that we were
so extraordinarily unprepared and had failed
leadership.
So now the question is, what do we do?
Do we need another lockdown?
Do we need like a six week coordinated, full
lockdown?
If that's what we need, it's never going to
happen.
I mean, you know, I'm talking about you really.
You don't leave your house without a mask.
You really don't go anywhere other than for
four essential trips, grocery store or whatever
the case may be.
And you'd have to do new stimulus payments,
I guess.
Is that what we actually need now?
Because when you look at 10000 cases a day
in Florida, 10000 cases a day in Texas, you
don't get that under control by saying, let's
just not go to bars.
Let let's not do indoor dining.
You just don't.
That's not how you get it under control.
Clearly, the summer heat isn't stopping it.
Clearly, it's just not going to disappear
in April, the way Donald Trump and so many
others said, we are nowhere near herd immunity.
But no matter what happens on that front,
you've got to be registered to vote.
And we have to remove this administration
in November, because no matter what happens
between now and November 3rd, we need someone
else at the helm.
That must happen.
And so we're going to talk about polling a
little later.
Let's not take our eye off the ball when it
comes to acting responsibly day to day on
Corona virus.
Let's do it and encourage everybody we know
to do it.
But when it comes to removing this failed
leader.
Not really, really even a leader.
We've got to not lose sight of that.
And that's coming up just just four months
from now.
Tuesday, we will be having the third ever
David Pakman show chess tournament.
You can register for free at David Pakman
dot com slash chess.
Hope you'll join us.
We'll also have a big one day membership special
on Tuesday, July 14th.
You can be notified about that simply by signing
up for my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
Let me know what's going on in your state.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.